Courtney Cox returns to the real friends
apartment and it gives us all the fields
the actress instagrammed her visit to
the iconic New York City street corner
used as the exterior of her character
Monica Geller's apartment in the hit 90s
sitcoms she completed her post with the
signature friends scene change music and
the caption the one where my rent went
up twelve thousand dollars it fit the
friend's apartment is located on the
corner of Bedford and Grove streets in
the city's West Village but it was only
used for establishing shot the show was
actually filmed on a soundstage in Los
Angeles
[Music]
five more and I'll flash ooh whoo in
January
Courtney had another friend throwback
moment this time on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show
I was calling Gunther to get us more
coffee oh he's not here no it's a set no
all right all right
I wish Lisa Kudrow was here because that
would be fun this is the actual couch
the host surprised her with the replica
of the couch from the show's Central
Perk coffee shop to be used as a prop in
her first Instagram pic but that wasn't
Ellen's only surprise to be there for
you
[Music]
friends will celebrate its 25th
anniversary this September I think the
show speaks for itself
I think that's we should just leave it
at that was Courtney back when it
premiered last month Courtney opened up
to ET about the show's early days while
promoting her new Facebook watch series
nine months with Courtney Cox I mean
this start was just these people getting
to know each other and becoming friends
and being such an amazing time we had
such great writers the whole thing was
the best experience that I could
possibly imagine I felt very lucky to
have been a part of that show and
everything kind of seems to pale in
comparison whenever I read comedies I'm
just like I can't compare just the
friendships the chemistry like I said
the writers the producers the whole
thing and here's why show creator Marta
Kauffman told ET she thinks friends
still resonates with people today my
hope is but it's because those are six
people you want to invite into your
house and you want to be friends with
them and you care about them and they
make you feel comfortable that's my hope
that's why seems like a safe assumption
Netflix dropped a reported $100,000 to
keep the show streaming for just one
more year
[Music]